[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts if
my kids steals another kid's toy yeah
I'm the other father hey man your your
kid just still we're at preschool dude
can they watch
what is there a window where we watch or
yeah we're watching yeah we're looking
after a [ __ ] two one-way mirror yeah
yeah it's like yeah it's like the feds
yeah yeah yeah so we're in that one-way
mirror yeah yo dude I just saw your kid
uh steal a toy from like my kid no no
[ __ ] yeah what kind of toy what do you
steal Tonka oh Tonka Truck Yeah he loves
Tonka trucks yeah so that's what you
would do do you have kids
yeah yeah what do you mean I'm not yeah
yeah that's yeah he loves those trucks
yeah you're not gonna what's that steal
just talk talk tell scold your kid
hey buddy
is that your truck
it's his right
good boy
that's what you would you got to take
what you want in this world and don't
let these little [ __ ] Asian pieces of
[ __ ]
I think I think what I want and that
racism start Asian hey yeah right right
so you're teaching two things I like
that no what if your kid if your kid
does something wrong don't no no I would
add to that that's what you would do
Tommy Tommy don't no no tell me tell me
don't know right tell me tell me no no
I would probably go to the other baby
I'm sorry I would I would always have to
have some sort of accent probably
I'm sorry right and I'll bring it back
give it back to the kid and give him the
toy bag right and tell me now we don't
no no right right Tommy my son right now
why not right
that's right why not and I would have to
come to you and call you probably yeah
why not I go let him steal the toys yeah
[Laughter]
is wild folks these guys already taped
an episode of The Joe Rogan Experience
earlier today where Shane famously drank
18 beers
yeah and I already died Ari's dead Mark
had a bunch of whiskeys and Ari shaffir
there's a slight chance that you were
here the day that Ari was supposed to be
on the show with these two and passed
away he was old he was he was on his way
out little [ __ ]
[Music]
he told Shane that he could stick with
him he's in Jewish hell
foreign
[Applause]
Germany
[Laughter]
stand up free Ukraine why did he laugh
there
I I just can't get over is that his wife
yeah yeah wow just a shocking
resemblance to Shane Gillis
like a
[ __ ] resemblance
I can't I honestly I tuned out the whole
thing I tuned up because
and everything going on here so is that
a Kaepernick hat
definitely not my pride kick in on [ __ ]
like this what with the podcast where
I'm like they always say yeah we can cut
something if you want I'm like [ __ ]
cut anything I stand on everything guys
even if it's something I'm like I
shouldn't have said that right oh yeah
I'm still you can't get in trouble
yeah there you go you don't understand
what it's like
[Laughter]
get in trouble for anything you say yeah
right yeah so it's pretty easy to stand
up and be like don't delete it yeah whoa
you're really taking a risk there you
talking about shaking a chick I would
never admitted that yeah for now
oh boy what about titty [ __ ]
nobody down yeah I don't have a problem
with it it's it doesn't it doesn't
um yeah it doesn't it doesn't hurt it
doesn't uh it's easy to do I think it's
kind of funny yeah it's funny it's funny
to watch a guy like [ __ ] about the jizz
when he hits you right in the lower uh
chin area I feel like it doesn't hit you
there I feel like it just goes in your
mouth I'm not trying to be I'm not
trying to be it's even better like
titillating I just think right
titillating if you're hey wherever it
wants I feel like it would usually just
go in my hair really no no no no we got
that hat
it's just bucket okay I haven't been 20
bucks since high school okay I've never
titty [ __ ] with those beauties
[Laughter]
comedy it's good to be on edge when
you're in fight camp Oh you think yeah
what is like a
caged up animal ready to fight yeah are
you super are you superstitious
yeah like when it comes to fight time
like do you have little things you're
like oh I don't do this tons of tons of
rituals okay a lot of meditation deep
breath work
um out loud manifestation okay
um
okay listen
just make what happens what do you make
happen you can't even manifest the
colors matching your outfits
and then come back here
let me stop stop it
you talk about colors what these I don't
see colors
colorblind person
on the podcast bro it's colorblind and
raisins the guy that does the color for
our podcast is actually colorblind
you're kind of it doesn't like Asians
you call black people the entrance you
did call them that
is this what is this it's an excuse me
do you think you could beat up miles
come on do you really think you could
beat a mouse I wouldn't do it huh I
wouldn't do it that's not fair why is it
not a fair fight because he's probably
going to have it taking charge
you guys are gonna storm your house
there's a cross burner Long Island City
right now
damn bro that's gonna be nice when you
finally ejaculate it's gonna feel so
much better when you do it I've played
with a woman yeah man when you do with
another person it's a whole different
thing even if you're just masturbating
and she's sucking your nipples because
you begged because you begged does that
happen sometimes yeah
that's my sex life is me masturbating be
like can you just please suck my nipples
that's pretty [ __ ] it's very nice
dude yeah I can imagine it's a serious
hack
any girl can wiggle out of a [ __ ] but
if you like can you just suck my nipples
they're like okay fine yeah okay fine
dude it's the real deal It's gotta be a
little disappointing for her though
probably like damn my husband's like a
[ __ ] freak
but like not in a good not like he
really [ __ ] me harder than any of that
it's like no he's like a weird he
squirms I suck his nipples dude while
you're jerking off not well not well
basically getting late it is getting
laid it it's getting late for sure it is
I'm not discount yes
that's like more sinful than most sex
acts that's for real that's bad dude
that's not that's bad dude that's
getting your release that's bad no way
there's a sweet release
I'm thinking about it and I would like
it you don't think you don't think I
want that
you don't think I wouldn't be doing that
stuff
you ever have this one where the guy
goes uh he goes you gotta try this this
chair it's a very comfortable chair and
you sit in the chair and you're like
this is very comfortable goes I told you
I know that's why I'm sitting in it that
is a specifically male problem I think
yes yes that's definitely something men
do together wanting Reddit yeah wanting
credit I told you when you like agreed
already like yeah yeah I meant I'm on
board I get that with a lot I have a
friend who'll send me videos like oh
that's funny he's like yeah you didn't
make the video I know what the [ __ ] are
we doing it was good good job finding it
yeah Jimmy and I told you when I when I
didn't believe you and then you proved
me right yeah the Twin Towers will be
fine
that'll be fine I told you that I'll get
all right I'll give you that one I do
feel like uh that is one of the ways
that like dudes can kind of relate to um
being coerced into sex is like if you've
ever been shown a YouTube video you
didn't want to watch by a good friend
oh fine you're like okay
thumbs down yeah
you're like I'll play nice I guess the
ending it'll pick up in the end
Cash pass benefits only on eligible
orders that meet the minimum subtotal
terms apply and we'll we'll probably use
it right after this I use it all the
time I use it all the time
you broke the cat that's hilarious we
have this one
we have more
oh my God
do you want to heard the machine story
for the first time what do you mean for
the first time the first time George
heard the machine Story how did she get
that lucky she hasn't heard that [ __ ]
thing
she went this long without him
she'd never heard that story ended let
them hear it she said they have to be 18
before you hear it and they actually
followed that and they followed the rule
what did she think Georgia had said to
me the day before that date Churchill
Downs someone said uh have you ever
heard the machine story he said no I
haven't heard it I said you haven't
heard it she goes mom wouldn't let us
listen to it I was like oh for real
you've never heard it she's like I mean
I know the story but I don't know what
it I know I've never heard it
so I brought her on stage and then I
brought I put her off to the side of the
stage so she could hear and I told the
story to her
and uh and it was it was it was I was
trust me when you say like telling that
story to my daughter I I told the story
great yeah like I really like I tell it
I give it 100 every night but like
telling it to George all my sides were
to her yeah and so
we'll get on stage I think Katella goes
oh what did you think of your dad's
story she goes it's [ __ ] right
[Laughter]
they're like huh she's like that's not
true there's no way that's [ __ ] true
right I go yeah it's true she goes no
it's not yeah
it's paying for
see I love that whenever you say
something they're like it's one of dad's
stories though dad's gonna tell you one
of his stories right now and then at the
end of the night I'll never forget this
she goes do you have any money and I go
yeah I got 20 bucks
and a couple cigarettes and she goes
take my cigarettes
and take my 40 bucks she had made like
50 bucks the night before at The Comedy
Store as a waitress and she goes take
that money I'd never taken money from a
woman before but that's not even in my
realm you know what I'm saying I'll rob
a [ __ ]
you know I rock I robbed a couple
[ __ ] in my day I robbed the chick
once I met at the comedy store I was
eating a [ __ ] and I'm trying to take
the money out of her pocket
when she picked me up and I didn't pick
up at The Comedy Store I picked her up
at the lab Factory she got thrown out of
Laugh Factory because he was heckling
Thomas
so when I got when I was leaving she
comes up to me she's like were your
feelings hurt I go no I didn't even know
you were that you know
and we started talking she's pretty cute
and she goes do you want to go get a
drink and I'm like yeah let's go get a
cocktail somewhere foreign
I didn't know any bars you know I'm not
a drink there so I didn't know any bars
so I said let's just go to a liquor
store oh my God Ryan sickler when we
went to the liquor store she bought a
vodka when she wasn't up first she took
out a [ __ ] gangster roll like 100
station wide cash oh my God this [ __ ]
is going down right I had like a gram of
coke maybe a little less I'm doing lines
I'm looking at that quad I'm like uh so
we got back to the hotel we're finished
we do a couple lines you know
she goes let me slip into something more
comfortable whatever the [ __ ] like I I
don't even know she put like a top on
that's what it was because she had on
like a tight thing with [ __ ] with her
tits popping out so she put on like a
bed thing but she had her jeans on her
shoes
and we started swapping and spit and she
stopped so she goes I have a boyfriend
I'm gonna be something like that it's
like when you do a virgin Catholic girl
on the walk home you gotta pet that back
there crying like
um
ah
so
this was swapping spit we're not even
doing nothing heavy and he would break
away and go I got a boyfriend I feel so
guilty I'm like where's your boyfriend
he's like in Seattle so [ __ ] don't worry
about it what's your man got to do with
me I got a man that's right I'm not
going to hear it you know what I'm
saying yeah I remember that song oh
one thing leads to another finite
topless I want to lick your [ __ ]
monkey and she can't
she can't take it so I take a little
jeans off and I'm watching that bulge
but what she did what she did to me was
that she took the gangster roll she took
the singles from the middle and she put
the singles on top now that made the
gangster roll a Jewish role
[Applause]
right and I'm taking out singles I'm
like what the [ __ ] and a [ __ ] had sweat
to it so it smelled kind of weird it was
like a Fear Factor type of [ __ ] fear
[ __ ]
I'm eating this hot sticky [ __ ] it
tastes like that the gyro sauce it's got
that little greek smell to it I mean
[ __ ]
I closed my nose without the fingers
digging in my [ __ ] with my tongue but
the whole time I'm trying to pickpocket
10 minutes back the episode I finally
got it for 200.
with a quarter in the meter
this is the funniest story ever I
[ __ ] get in that car and I shoot to
Dante's house the drug dealer it's five
to one I just made it I go in I go
here's 200 give me 200 worth of coke he
goes you owe me 50 from the island no
worries and I'll say he looks at me goes
you smell funny
and I go yeah I was eating some old
Greek [ __ ]
it smelled like something out of Jimmy's
Seafood
who's the most distracting on Sunny set
getting a day done
distracting yeah like who on this who
there's always like a few actors or at
least one person on set who makes the
days a little bit longer Danny yeah he
turns into God forbid we have background
actors in the scene he just turns into
he's just like
I'm like have you not had enough days
where you're the center of attention he
just is like is he like [ __ ] with
everybody oh yeah putting on a show he
gets a 50 year old woman to laugh at him
and he's in heaven think about what that
feels like for the background person
come on they love it so much and it's
really great but if it's we're outside
and it's 100 degrees and I'm like
it's almost time for me to go home I'm
like can we just could we see the scene
or did you want to see that guy I gotta
rap with these guys butt jokes with the
background person who you're never gonna
see again definitely Danny for sure see
he's like the most why he's like the
most Wild on his own yeah he'll just get
in a mood and he'll just start like
[ __ ] with the director and being like
that doesn't make sense make it make
sense it's usually like a guest director
that's one of Rob's friends yeah and
just explodes everything see I think
they deserve that though when somebody
comes in no they get it I like that yeah
yeah light them up a little bit yeah
yeah have you ever have you guys ever
had to fire a director that's come
that's done such a poor job it was like
we can't do this anymore and you don't
need to say the name no but there's
plenty I'll tell you the name um because
at you guys level it's some it's kind of
hard to change stuff why would you [ __ ]
with the thing it's also yeah it's a
very specific look there's a specific
formula yeah it works and also fart
laugh yeah [ __ ] fart
sometimes you throw a vagin there you
know because often not often but that's
what makes it so funny when it does pop
up exactly right throw a veg in there
that's throw a vagina yeah
here's where we stick in a quick badge
and then uh and then you move every once
in a while yeah
throwing a badge should be the name of
an episode and I don't need credit but
it's fine it should be the name of one
episode all right I'll come up with
something
[Music]
what about soap what are you using using
body wash using a bar
nah I'm not a soap guy I'm not a soap or
shampoo dude so you just rinse off yeah
basically you know you're [ __ ] with
this no that's that's my thing
you don't use any soap in the shower
rarely
that's insane what yeah hot water it's
not good for you
I'm telling you probably not yeah go
look at the studies yeah that's why
everyone's allergic to everything holy
[ __ ]
I don't have it's probably got a point
I'm the only person I know that has no
acid reflux no allergies never taken my
lunch Mylanta never taken to Tums never
had heartburn has no foodborne allergies
can eat I did that show hot ones I got
up to the Scoville scale of like 35
million I left the place people are like
how do you feel and I'm like feel
exactly as I felt
and they're like and they're like oh but
the next morning on the toilet man
you're gonna pay the price like I
couldn't even tell that I what I've
eaten or done I can eat any shellfish I
can eat any I can eat stuff that's
rotted I can eat stuff that if I got
cottage cheese and it's got green hair
on it I'll just spoon it off throw it no
you think this all comes down and not
use an Irish Spring
all roads I need to see the science on
this really quick just want to say thank
you for watching this video and let you
know we're going to continue to do this
for every month moving forward so in the
last day of every month we'll do a best
moments from all the major podcasts so
we'll do one for August next month and
so on I don't need to explain to you how
months work but thank you for watching
and please subscribe right now so you
don't miss anything back to the video
last week on tigerbelly they announced
that they have broken up they are broken
up to continue to do the podcast so I am
the first guest I am the first guest on
their new on on the podcast okay and if
you remember
last year when I went on tigerbelly
after we split the history hyenas
Bobby and kalila
wore shirts or Bobby Lee wore a shirt
that said Team Yana the team Yana shirt
it's coming well tomorrow and we've got
it made vanity is doing it ah and it was
his homeless pimps idea I got to give
him all the credit
I'm going on to tigerbelly with a
button-down shirt and I'm going to open
it at some point in the podcast and it
will say team kalilah
oh yeah yeah
[Laughter]
yo it's the same shirt
[Music]
[Music]